ah hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to visit the game that
everybody says is terrifying if you look
on Steam you'll see a bunch of review oh
you'll see a bunch of reviews that kind
of back up this statement it's got a 94
percent rating some people are saying
they've never been so scared of a game
it's a fantastic horror game with great
pasting that builds slowly and maintains
it the whole way through now I've played
a lot of horror games in my days and
I've been disappointed by false hype
before but I'm willing to let myself be
a little bit excited that there's a good
horror game that I hadn't heard of until
just recently so you guys ready
oh that was my back I don't know if you
could heard that but you guys ready you
guys ready for this boobage
you guys ready for this poop because
it's starting right now we're not
waiting for anybody visit is hard oh
[ __ ] patience thorough and oh god
thorough investigation good resource
management are your best friends that's
not what I'm good at
that's the opposite of what I do good I
do that bad I just feel bad ok but I got
some Resident Evil I think I can get
through this just fine oh come on oh I
love lamp come on come on baby
you have never heard of sad Square
studios but thanks for a good name I
hope I got the volume right I want it
nice and loud for you mmm that's their
gun
this is gonna be hand simulator oh okay
I don't like where that's going yeah I
don't like where this going yeah this
seems bad yes bad yes what you would
call bad yeah is broadband
mmm I'm uncomfy I'm super uncomfy right
now oh boy dad I don't like this doll I
don't like this
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what kind of
opening in the game is that what is that
what is all that about I was gonna have
a nice spooky time oh you know the kind
of spooky that's like spooky scary
skeletons come creeping that's gonna be
like that thing is gonna be a Booma
Bangi nightmares horribleness oh god now
it's sloppy
oh no oh alright I was a pts [ __ ] what
is going on here oh my god okay all
right well then hi that was a start of a
game how you oh we can I go back again
you need the garage room key I just came
from there oh don't you hate it when you
leave a room and you're like oh I forgot
the key to the door inside of my house
Oh whoopsie doopsy oh boy okay so I got
some kind of ritual room here I'm a
little up a little lopsided at the
moment but I think that's okay there's a
kind of a nice ritual room there and
there's the inviting glow of
horribleness downstairs oh hey hello
Jesus
okay alright I'm gonna go up here cuz I
mean it's already gotten bad so might as
well go from bad to worse I I suppose
nice door physics okay I'm gonna make it
louder for me I don't really get smooth
progress room oh this room is a hub
containing items that represent your
progress throughout the game these items
are collected in different ways
including the end of a chapter once
collected these items will automatically
appear in the progress room great cool
what kind of progress severed heads cut
out hearts ball sacks just laid out I
don't know what kind of progress I'm
being measured here but just judging by
the beginning of this game I don't think
it's gotta be nice ooh what do we got
here a dildo a candle now it's very
close candles are stationary lights that
can be lit with a lighter moving around
with a candle
calls it to extinguish they last a long
time and act as light sources that help
increase your character's sanity oh so
like am Norcia I see okay I'm with you
on that one can i oh I literally have to
hold it I can't let it go there we go
okay okay let's light her up
let's lighter Oh store where did it go
it went down towards my dick but I think
it's okay I think it went in my pocket
okay interact so except some sort of
displaced and there's nothing on it okay
and some chairs to look at get your
knees burnt off by the candles okay
thank you said this hop in day I don't
know who you are blood okay
oh I don't like where you look at me
nothing this is nothing that is
something but very clearly you're
telling me that that's nothing so I'm
gonna ignore it and move on okay goodbye
light no okay we got to save power for
some reason all right see a creepy altar
room that I have in my house for some
reason already I'm gonna cut you off
this is hard pass on that one
there's no I've been through the ringer
on certain horror movies games all sorts
of stuff you never answer the phone when
it's ring-a-ling dinging so I'm just
gonna ignore that say I ignore that
right away
oh those apple cores or beer cans those
cigarettes didn't know bendy in the egg
machine was part of this all right here
let's just put this in my pocket all
right okay store that in the wall there
that's fine all right okay thank you
okay we got some notes there got some
stuff there shut up I'm not gonna answer
you whoa this looks ominous can I this
action is impossible to movement
this action is impossible there's no
possible way that this action Oh hmm
this one work but this one don't
something tells me that I'm not sure
sanity will affect her gameplay
standing too long in the dark will
decrease your character sanity amongst
varying other elements your character
sanity is represented by the brain icon
in the lower left corner of the screen
if you see the brain clearly your
character sanity is dangerously low and
dangerous events will occur the black
cloud icon appears when you were in a
stressful situation when which decreases
your character sanity okay am I in a
stressful situation is this situation a
little stressful I don't sense no stress
untrust
paranormal events occur randomly
throughout the game learn to identify
these paranormal events as they hinder
your progress and decrease your sanity
greatly thank you AJ foxy did the bite
of 87 that's helpful that is helpful
that's helpful probably nothing probably
nothing available in the
[Music]
light bulbs can be used to repair broken
lights or lamps okay all right but I
want to hear about Dwayne Anderson
Dwayne Dwayne is that you also I have a
funny feeling I know what's gonna happen
in this that's a little noisier than it
should be okay I need the basement key
I'm just gonna go lay of the land I'm
just getting a lay of the land I just
want to lay of the land I want to lay
the land and then once I go hey I want
to lay of the land
I want to lay land land lay I can't see
candle do I have lighter I like lamp
I need lamp toilet why is there a door
here hello that's too slow I'm laying
some land the layout of this house is
weird can I just say that straight up a
little bizarre oh okay weird closet okay
totally fine
seems hunky duty seems hunky-dory
everything seems fine in this game
just you know a house at night and
probably some kind of a kid's bedroom
that I definitely didn't murder
it's a rolled-up newspaper can I use it
- whap some demons that come after all
right okay okay okay I don't know why
this turned off
but I got a bottle of shampoo that's
always helpful how do I get through here
I'm just gonna blaze through it cuz I'm
a badass here we go easy peasy did I
hear a rat
all right I'm gonna go back no there's
only one other door here to check so I
might as well check it I mean I know I'm
gonna have to come through back here
again eventually but I just want to see
I just want to see hello me
oh I'm not there okay well that's fun oh
is this bad for my health lighter weight
lighters are used as a minor source of
light to explore the house they last for
a limited amount of time they will not
prevent stress buildup standing in the
dark with a lighter will decrease your
character sanity why why why would that
decrease it Napoleon I feel like you
would increase it hoosh am I going crazy
I might be going crazy okay alright okay
I think I've got everything you just
stand on my bed
for a little bit okay why what happened
who's that the ghost of my mother not
telling me to jump on the bed
you can't tell me what to do woman if I
wanna jump on my bed I'm gonna jump you
jump on my bed anyway yeah okay so I
guess I got to go answer this phone call
whatever
as if yeah right oh it's not ring-a-ling
in anymore
it was my footprints
those are not my footprints hi
oh you're persistent ain't you oh you're
persistent nature
alright fine whatever worried I haven't
seen you out of the house in about three
weeks is everything all right could you
call me just to let you know
everything's fine all right bye
all right okay so I'm Dwayne does that
mean I was called on the radio show
that's pretty cool I guess so um so um
what am I gonna do I gotta be looking
for no no no no nope nope
okay that works
this action is still impossible at the
moment why his dissection still
impossible there we go no that's not
right okay let me examine you examine
seems to be working properly then why is
this action impossible also I didn't
notice this door here
oh that's right I did notice that door
there okay
it's jammed it's nothing okay
fascinating so pray tell so pray tell
what uh what dust thou want from me
confession hello oh I don't know I guess
back to the other side of the house I go
I probably should Oh probably should I
answer that phone earlier maybe whatever
beggars can't be choosers I do what I
can do you'll run that by me again wait
what oh that's a tree I thought that was
a person standing out there okay that
would have been creepy good thing this
game ain't about being cool whoa I
didn't notice the basement before can i
I light the candle how do I get a candle
out where's my inventory key inventory
no where's my inventory I'm thinking
gimmick candle what buttons my candle
don't where's my candle button where's
but there's the zoom button there's a
Crouch button I don't have a there here
we go okay candle let's hold
how do we light it how do i how do i
light it how do i wait no no no give me
give me give me okay here we go there we
go got it all right you're gonna be that
doesn't help that doesn't help at all
all that helps the opposite of any help
okay well whoa oh that's better okay I
didn't even know that was the thing okay
need the garage room key okay so I still
need the same thing I needed before so
I'm gonna take this can I take this take
this okay it's out storage okay cool all
right I'm gonna hang this I'm getting
that idea what's going on what what what
what what what happened what happened I
didn't see it
okay thank you
you need the basement key still this is
still jammed
this is still jammed okay back upstairs
I go I suppose hey lights work up there
no looky loo you oh you found drawing of
a panda that's a that's terrifying
bandar that's horrifying all right here
we go Oh key inventory cool all right
cool Lucy's friend and insidious friend
white Y insidious Y hint avoid standing
of that I'm trying not to powder how do
it god the controls are not the most
intuitive I've ever seen I didn't see
that before was this always open I think
it was okay so I'm gonna why okay I'll
store that variety radio why are you out
of saving when I go in this room why are
you doing that oh hey Oh
um okay well that's a little weird
hey that okay anything in here nothing
all right
okay whoa hey whoa what is that is there
something in there or not you better not
you better not
you better not better not
you better not you better not oh hey oh
hey whoa
some by me okay good cuz there's
something in here I can't I can't
I'm knockin there's no knocks back
anymore knock when did I turn on that
light I don't like you you're horrible
hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa whoa hello
oh that's not normal that's not normal
that's not normal that's not normal
why is this house so weirdly laid out
that's not normal
that's not normal okay all right listen
very listen listen up closely if there's
something behind me you will tell me
that there's something behind me right
if there ever is a moment where there's
something that might just maybe be
behind me this is the master bedroom why
is why is this lead to that why is it
all lead in a big circle unless they
wanted me to run away from something but
if there's something behind me you will
tell me right hey boos all right that
makes a little better okay that's a lot
of pills that's a lot of viagra that is
just an extensive amount all right okay
nothing in here all right
so who
yeah
why did that go boom
okay all right not gonna go down that
way go down ah good
the study and look the really really
dark studying nook why is it so dark
okay there we go okay what kind of
studying nook is this it's locked
nothing indicates which key unlocks it
okay maybe the picture of the Panda
would I don't know nothing nothing oh oh
let me take a comfortable seat even
though it does nothing for me okay can I
stand up thank you I like how I enter
through the back of the chair I don't
need that can you please stop that
that'd be great
I'd be wonderful if you could stop doing
that okay oh dish was on before okay all
right
anybody anybody wanna play game peekaboo
down here oh this loops back to where I
was okay so that's not so bad what is
that is that something I need to know
about is that just hinge that's broken
off probably hinges broken off also
where is that why did you autosave is
there a reason for that
Oh cellar or attic the opposite of a
cellar content not available in ER yeah
says the of course it isn't then what is
available what do i do what do i do and
how do I get down to there what is that
I've never seen the TV I've never seen a
TV before in my life there's something
behind that ok well that's that's
definitely a thing all right I guess
it's just like a slow exploration to try
to figure
my sanity is decreasing fat why why is
it why would it be decreasing quickly
why
bye-bye what [ __ ] don't do that to me
you think you can but you cannot you can
think you think you're allowed but you
are not alright you know what I don't
know what's going on down here and
frankly I don't like it
but I am a big brave boy and I will
pigley bravely go wherever you don't
want me to go which i think is back in
here cuz I found the drawing and there's
a teddy bear here so I gotta assume what
is that howling why that howling no go
away
John me okay you what was with the
knocking what kind of knocking was that
all about
hey hey well well that's weird
Oh Mike what your gut stuck you could
stick the lighter okay all right bye
light whoo
see you later okay why are you where's
your hand like that that's weird are you
supposed to hold something can I give
you this my lighter
I dropped it can I give you like can I
give you
where's the light switch can I give you
the damn I keep dropping it um
store tab with the pillow
I've where'd the picture go dad drop it
I've dropped it didn't I okay hang on
open this again where did it go where
did it go
where did it go that's open now where
oh this is open a bull put them high
that's its plant that's a plant that
lets plant I thought it was arms and
legs thought it was legs dogs alright um
big [ __ ] baby oh you suck
open open open says me all right I'm up
no okay
now I did not ask to be dict with this
perfuse Lee hello
Matt's my favorite show what the hell
guys show is this oh no turn back on I
want no no my favorite show oh my
favorite
oh my favorite show and also convenient
source of light well [ __ ] I probably
ruin that forever Oh back yay
this just oh okay what do we have here
Oh Christmas Christmas Wow
Christmas Acapulco hotel choir okay
three Gracia together is there like some
clue here dad and Sara dunes oh hey okay
the clams alright thank you for that I'm
trying to look at some gosh darn clues
here you keep throwing me off with all
your weird things happening hey pills
are you know what you know what you know
what you keep doing stuff and I don't
like it that's the that that's the thing
let me open this some more where's my oh
I dropped it again could God cuz f is
usually the flashlight thing and I'm
like no dude no that should do that but
then I drop it okay that's jammed okay
so I can't go in there but is there
anything in there that would be of value
no it's not even letting me look at it
so is there anything else here of value
no no no no no all right there we go
please that got those on I don't know
why the TV's still frozen the way it is
but I'm just gonna assume that's gonna
be that way for a while and I gotta go
around it
what is that howling what's with the
howling what's what's with the howling
no I won't take my pills I don't need
viagra
I don't Nate it you think I need to be
walking around this this this house with
a fear boner I don't need it I don't
need no viagra I don't need no pills if
I get a fear boner of my own volition
that's what happens that's what nature
calls for but until then I won't
medicinally supplement I won't do it
anyway I gotta figure this out
so I ever
I got figure this out content not
available in early access okay I'm gonna
go back the first area and very
meticulously comb through everything
because it seems like I'm missing
something and there's a see what's all
this about
it's a box but what's in the box nothing
all right
but that was something to check and I've
not seen everything that I need to check
you nah mean oh eun-ah mean okay okay
how about in between the seat cushions
can I get some coins some spare change
of some kind and I get this here can I
read books can ice Oh candle see candle
this store was this no store okay oh no
take that
alright examine these what are these I
don't know weird ass things all bare hmm
okay a weird bird thing hmm but nothing
important
apparently there's an elephant here a
bunny wabbit I can't grab the other ones
only the elephant so I'm about the
elephant is important know in here why
did it get quiet
why did it get quiet why does it get
quiet where did it get quiet oh that
just ban everybody that's backseat
gaming bantam hard Bantam perma ban
everybody I'm gonna drop this can I
break it no one is allowed to backseat
game not while I the incredible genius
marque mu is here okay so this was
jammed that's locked the basements
locked there's some kind of a signature
who was that it's molding that's fine I
got it
okay nothing on the paintings that's not
available okay
it is an odd thing early access
considering what this is
ohayo key there are two types of keys
key items and dynamic items dynamic
items are stored when possible in your
dynamic inventory they are usually
discarded all key items are essential to
your progress and are stored in your key
inventory okay
all right cool the fee the key is tagged
basement I'd have no idea what that
would be even to I have no idea
oh well the mystery goes on I'll
probably figure it out once I get
through it combing through everything
but until then I just can't figure that
one out that one's just beyond me my
great brain just can't possibly like
particulate the the illusion of that
puzzle it must be like a master level
puzzle right there buts don't worry
don't worry I have faith I will solve
that puzzle as unsolvable as it may seem
I will figure out what that key is for
but until then I continue to comb
somewhere here there's a piece of the
puzzle that I'm not gonna miss no way no
how no way no how there's no way and
there's no how I know which way that I
go and I
know where I'm going to it so I'm gonna
go there and I'm gonna know there hmm
what do you guys think left right
it's got to be upstairs something like
that's got to be something that's got to
be upstairs right one would only assume
I drop my blighter there you are get
back here you sassy yeah there would
only be there would only be so many
places that a key like that
it was long let's look at it again hang
on everybody look at it hang on wait
let's look at it examine here we go all
right it's yellow what is yellow
represent in the color of the rainbow
I believe the yellow let me look it up
let me look it up let me look up a
rainbow I think I'm onto something I
think I'm onto something okay rainbow
okay if you got a rainbow the color
yellow
okay all right the color yellow is in
the middle it's in the middle so in the
middle somewhere maybe it's part of CMYK
hers it's ey m'kay it's a color thing
there's some color coding to this okay
it's a long penis like key with ring
with two loop it's got two loops so it's
on the second floor in the middle room
and it's got the most penis like
decorations I've got this on lock and if
I know where that is it's in the master
bedroom in the middle with the most
penis pills possible got it okay so I
just got a jam in this key somewhere in
here and I'm gonna find this don't worry
about it I got okay all right I got
don't worry I got this guys
you thought I wouldn't have it told you
genius-level intellect here knows beyond
know see wait here Oh sake sake hole
keyhole sake where was it I just saw it
I was there I saw it you saw you saw it
I saw it we all saw it it was right
right right hang on I got this and and
with what dope man I saw it it was right
there it was there something was there
something was actually there okay I just
dropped that again all right okay
well seems like seems like yellow lamp
perfect I knew it no okay
wow this mystery is unsolvable I think
this game is broken I'm pretty sure what
the basement what are you out of your
gourds are you out of your collective
dorit's have you not been taking your
viagra how could you even think remotely
that would be the key to the basement
what oh you silly you silly all right
let's try okay
this is the garage room key wait what
else would be the basement if this
wasn't the basement this key cannot
unlock that door okay so we need to [ __ ]
oh I know where the basement door is I
got it it's in the middle see this is in
the middle compared to everything so the
yellow was a clue oh yeah that's good
that's good that's good all right hello
hi diddly ho ho hey hey neighbor
another whoa I'm unstoppable I'm
unstoppable I've got to know how the
hell okay hang on - okay I'm gonna run
this one dry and then I'll switch to the
other one okay it's locked you need the
basement key well I have the basement
key where does that go though
oh this leads to the kitchen okay all
right okay oh yeah you can't stop me
once I start dual wielding lighters you
know it's only a matter of time no time
for a tasty beverage tasty beverage can
I store this wait I can okay let's drop
these [ __ ] candles and wait what my
dynamic inventory is full well I've got
too many candles obviously can I just um
wait can I just uh can I put this here
and just leave it there for later and
I'll know where it is and I'll keep a
tasty beer on me at all times so that I
can have it whenever I need that is
perfect oh god how big is this house
what the hell Mouse heard something okay
maybe I can move this out of the way
make it more easy to go back oh yeah
shove that shove it good just yeah
really give it a shove shove it shove it
hard there we go
that's good stuff oh by the way thank
you everybody that's giving super chats
I know I haven't been reading them I've
been trying to focus on the game more
than anything because number one it's
taking all my brainpower to be it
concentrated on this moment but also
just thank you everybody but you don't
need to really you don't don't don't
give me super to anything give a super
chat or give money to any other streamer
any other like youtuber that deserves it
more than I do which is everybody and
thank you everybody that's become a
member of the channel as well all right
let's see what's behind this door hello
hello oh god
why is this all just loop around oh well
here we go oh yeah this looks fun
this looks really fun
this looks so fun I love this this is
the best that's dark
I'm not gonna go there okay fire
extinguisher cool
anybody want a tasty beverage oh this
really doesn't cast much light at all
does it
Oh hoarseness something tells me I went
through this basement backwards and I
was supposed to go through it the other
way but Here I am it's not a mannequin
oh god I wish I went down this basement
the other way something tells me I would
have gotten light switches where's my
candle where's my candle where's Mikey
ah where's McKenna let's put a candle
down right there I'm gonna pull out my
lighter blah pull out my later let my
later light that bad boy and suddenly
we've got no more light than we had
before
okay great that didn't mean no good
maybe I can cure if I if I carry it real
slow like nope [ __ ] well oh wait now
this is pumping more light out oh
because it's a fresh lighter that's
right okay well I'll put this right
right there
light it up and that did nothing look
did nothing Oh God okay well [ __ ] we're
boned anyway so let's just keep going
and um hope for the best
like light bright light bright bright
light in the light tonight
Oh a turlet okay good great what is that
well what kind of house is so big
Oh content not available in early accent
what am I looking at movie not available
look over there oh oh hi Hulk you know
oh this is this is where I was supposed
to go this is where I was supposed to go
I was supposed to go down here first and
I didn't I went the wrong way but that's
okay you know what hello Oh mark box
tiny box damn you there I hear someone
[Music]
he's looking at this Vaz don't mind me
just trying to avoid whatever the hell
is over there the bulb okay
switch okay I've got two light bulbs uh
cold brewski and two candles and there's
another candle right there I'll get that
later
let me stop using my lighter so much
don't I oh hey okay you want a brewski
hey I've got a nice ice-cold beer here
with your name on it I'm just gonna put
this here
oh you're just gonna drop this by the
threshold beer for the ghost
for the demon I'm sorry okay I'm gonna
just oh that's good autosave perfect
time what was that wait what was that
Oh Oh what am I
okay cab have that okay switch hands
store nope store okay close oh okay I
get to do this down oh wait what oh okay
so little girl got a needle in the arm
oh boy I don't know what that is
hole boy okay
oh wow friend
oh boy friend okay all right
Oh whew well that looks good okay
hello did you accept my cold brewski you
didn't okay well I'll leave it there
cousin hey wait a minute
hold the phone hold every phone cut the
phone lines hold that phone hold my cell
phone
what is that
hey how you doing you want a cold
brewski you want a brewski hey I got
your brewski
brewski for the demon brewski
through the demon moon demon Paul that's
legs okay that's legs that's that's legs
alright that's a beer and that's legs
alright you want a beer how about a beer
no beer ok beer oh no ok
you know I changed my mind I'm gonna
leave this right there you have the beer
you take the bear take the bear
take the bear let's stop walking towards
me and take the bear I mean the Bears
towards me so just stop when you reach
the beer all right there you seem to be
slipping in and out of the material
realm
oh you're backing up ok you don't want
the bear oh I'm sorry do you like wine I
can get wine you like wine what do you
like better beer or wine I don't know ok
okay all right well no beer for you then
no beer no beer why why not the beer I
got this tasty beer you didn't take it
what is this
there was another lighter over there too
storage room dynamic items that are
essential to your progress will respawn
in the storage room located in the
basement when left behind oh that's
handy but I gotta go in the basement to
go get it that's not as handy that's not
that handy that's that's not that handy
[Music]
okay Oh plate
great I love plate Oh more of this why
do we have an extra one of those does
that blink pay oh god that's horrible oh
oh oh these my children Oh Dwayne man
you really uh maybe shouldn't have taken
so much viagra it's all I got to say
about that okay so what the hell
happened over here I'm gonna leave that
beer there for now ah handy that let me
just let me get a closer look at this
huh well not a closer look yeah that's
pretty good put it right up to my
eyeball hmm I can't tell what it is oh
is that what that what uh
okay it's still aligned let me grab that
tasty beer again just in case it seemed
to thwart her so I can get it again
she definitely definitely will drink it
what my beer okay okay protect me beer
oh look it I'm going up the exit the way
that I came in cuz I'm an idiot cuz I'm
a goddamn idiot no matter what I do I
always do things the wrong way the way
they're not supposed to be done it's
kind of ends here oh no no doesn't why
okay that's fine I gotta go get my beer
alright want to put this away wait hang
on I'm gonna I'm gonna leave a candle
here let's grab this let's drop the
candle right there so I know where it is
okay that's fine okay
I'm gonna put this in I'm gonna put this
away I know I'm gonna need this beer no
I'm gonna put it Amman put it away one
okay okay oh the ceiling huh okay which
way you're going
I see okay all right this way
whoo beer I don't see where wasn't there
didn't that didn't that it just stops
okay no no but the beer take the beer
take a projector beer
I've got some lightbulbs I can fix
something
where's the light I need to store this
pull out my lighter I'm still gonna use
this hose well I went up on the desk
still getting use this whole system
fine where's oh hey you're here forever
now I don't like that where's the light
where's the light where is the light can
maybe I don't need to fix this okay it's
fine I'll buy put on your big-boy pants
and let's go to it and I'll freak it out
let's do this cuz there's nothing to be
afraid of there's nothing to be afraid
of you know why cuz we got beer and
apparently I can open and close doors
with beer and I like that
okay so I don't know where to go now
though cuz I got that was there like
something on the floor that I was
supposed to see cuz I can't see [ __ ] to
be very specific so I'm gonna put a
candle right there I'm gonna get my
lighter out light that bad boy up and
that doesn't help me at all that just
makes it look worse maybe I could nudge
it over drop it
there we go okay that's horrible now I'm
all my suspicions are confirmed that's
horrible okay so this is me no good
alright then where my beer go where did
I drop my beer
there's my beer I'm a tasty beverage
I don't know what else this game wants
for me gotta be something else right
something else that can be flashed what
about this knocking thing is knocking
nonsense still nothing
okay there's got to be something else
then I'm fine by the way I'm fine why
are you all worried about me I'm fine
don't worry about me
I am a okay a to the okay nothing
nothing at all just a whole lot of
nothing I don't like that
okay whole lot of nothing so once I did
that then it's got to be something else
it had to have like unlocked something
you know what I mean there would be
something else like like a round there
had to be a reason maybe I could did I
even try to interact with this no
there's nothing to be done yeah okay oh
I didn't even know that was ready
anymore all right
that's okay let me go back down to wait
suddenly that drawing isn't just the
drawing anymore now that's in what the
hell what what is it fog here why is it
well this door always read it was not
who's not something's happening I'm not
doing that I'm not doing it don't oh oh
okay
guilt huh is it guilt from murdering my
family cuz I was pretty messed up hey be
ahead bear who wants up here who not a
light bulb
who wants a tasty beer I got you covered
a brewski come on some brewski
oh come on now ha ha ha come on bear no
okay alright beer this is lovely by the
way this is just this is gosh darn
lovely hmm boy sure I'm thirsty hmm I
don't feel bad if anybody out there
didn't have something cold and luscious
to quench their thirst like a tasty beer
what the hell is going on here thank you
solid eggs Leia oh hello there Lou how
are you doing oh this is horrible hmm
this is this is awful this is not good
Oh bad I don't like this at all I like
this the least this is the least thing
that I like this is about the least
thing I've ever liked Oh treehouse hmm
cornerstone of every childhood and a
bunch of of I don't even know what those
are but a bunch of those oh it's
beautiful beautiful kind of ruined by
this beer maybe I'll put it away I think
I might have to decline this ladder
although I don't know
I want to go up here blood I've been
going on so let me put that away
let me put put dis away I'm gonna climb
this ladder nope oh there we go yo
you're here we go hello hi how are you
oh you're grumpy okay
I'm Lucy okay I'm Lucy hello Lucy I want
to be your friend a Skoosh mad
Skoosh friend did it
aha perfectly normal for children to
just narrate their entire existence like
this yeah okay okay boy I'm glad I'm up
here what's in here
you need the small key oh I see the
small key right well all that just about
enough of this unless there's a small
key around here swaha what Oh Oh goodbye
apparently what was that
well what was that what was that
okay seal nope still big nope on that
one
I can't leave so there's got to be
something else that I need to solve here
right thing above something below as
above so below
mmm something in the rafters some kind
of small key alright so if this is a key
I was a kid and I was gonna hide a key
somewhere in this place oh I would hide
it here you want throttle these little
teddy bears until they give me a key
I'll just shake them just absolutely
destroy all of them all right listen
I've already done something horrible at
the beginning of this game I had a gun
with six bullets and I only use four of
them so I've got two left
who's it gonna be huh who's gonna give
up this key huh who's gonna give up a
key haha
which one is yes it's gonna give up I
don't know who wants a beer huh okay two
people a bullet and one person a beer
who's gonna get a beer huh okay maybe
it's buying one of these
I didn't look fine to all of them so
it's Godby I'm smarter than a child I am
a genius I'm of an intellect of 2010
looks nice
so
okay all right who wants a beer wants a
beer the power of beer compels you no
don't get rid of me Lucy take the bear
Lizzie only the beer help Lizzie Lizzie
don't do it don't don't get rid of it
take the bear where are you Lucy
Bluth a booth a all right Lucy trying to
think you're not taking this seriously
Lucy Wow bareback oh then I'll and
that's a long fall Oh what the hell
wait wait no wait wait what these are my
this is my flight's which friends what
did you do with my light switches
oh my beer wait no my beer huh thank
goodness oh I thought they took away my
light switches but I thought they took
away my beer everybody hush hush hush
everybody I've got a crisis don't you
know this is a scary game I got a deal
with this okay hang on I don't have any
lights anymore which is a problem but
that's okay cuz we can solve problems
how through the power of togetherness
and friends we can solve this stop
saying the power of beer compels you
stop
what the [ __ ] okay oh that's not good
okay that's not good no no no no no no
god damn it okay I drop both of those
god damnit can't control no there's
another beer I don't need it no that's
that's that's the right one okay store
that my synergy is high I'm trying I'm
trying to let me just watch the tube for
a bit my sanity okay okay I don't I'm
trying to here we go okay here we go
what's who's in here content not
available okay then I guess I don't need
to worry about that the weird breathing
less here okay lock but no key okay this
is fine it was this in here like that
woo another lighter okay grab that spore
that hi what in the [ __ ] you know what I
don't do whatever you're doing just
don't do it I need whatever you're
pulling my beer did you take my beer
your undoing is now inevitable
what tips will pry my sanity right my
sanity that's right I guess what huh
okay let's try again I didn't take my
viagra I don't have any viagra I don't
need it
you don't think I need I don't need it I
don't need it
candles I know what candles do game I'm
fully aware of the power of candles do I
still have my beard good okay I'm taking
this lighting that I'm gonna take oh
good so many lighted there's so many
lighters you know what that's great
because you know why I must avoid
sitting in the dark for too long and
that's good so what I got to do now is
start lighting these up put toys back in
their basement rules put toys back close
the TV when leaving the base yeah
because you close the TV that's right
and then do anything else that you would
normally do okay so I'm getting out of
the basement that's my number one thing
right now
yeah the basement get out of the
basement okay this is the storage I
don't need to be in storage I gotta get
out of the basement okay I can't do that
okay I think I remember the basement
exit being over here oh thank you oh why
oh I don't want any of that no thank you
no thank you close the door get some
beer hey where's my beer good dirt dang
it Bethlem
[Music]
you still coming okay good
where's that candle there it is like
that nope
put the bear away no don't drop the
goddamn thing okay there okay
alright now that we're back here let's
carry on still not sure what I'm
supposed to try to do well let's try to
do it okay okay so all of these are now
busted so I might as well start trying
to put some back in its place right I
might as well okay so I'm gonna try fix
like this one what seems to be working
properly well you know so not so do
so what so what do i do I can't light
them anymore so I can't really do
nothing but but what are you there why
are you there
why are you there stop being there stop
beer go now
beer I choose you be right Suzy watches
you beer
[Music]
I don't know why that's happening here's
the thing I don't know why I don't know
why and I don't know what I'm supposed
to do
frankly I don't know what I'm supposed
to do so I'm gonna keep exploring what
happened am i later does that dropped my
lighter i dropped my lighter again
didn't I
god damn it I got to go back in the
basement getting more lighter in Kadel I
don't think the lightbulbs are gonna do
me any good by the way I don't think the
light bulbs are gonna do me any sort of
good anymore cuz I can't flip a switch I
can't flip switch what this beers
evolved about I can't stop I can't flip
switch so how can I do anything I don't
where did what okay whatever I don't I'm
dying I'm so screwed because I have no
idea where I'm going no God is horrible
oh this is the worst oh boy I hate this
okay there we go okay I just got to get
back grab some candles grab some switch
out the lightbulb Can I grab these why
do you think that was the thing that I
want to do it dark better help hell bear
bear oh you're fast you're not but you
do fast kid you got a drinking problem
okay are you done you're done
can I get my goddamn beer and watch my
TV in peace dad drop it huh okay give me
that store it give me that store it no
not the beer store it I'm gonna carry
this one just because I feel like it oh
god the power of beer is not compelling
her I keep trying but it's not working
the beer won't repair the lights the
beer can fix a lot of problems but I
think it's like I think I'm gaining some
wisdom like beer does create more
problems than it solves
why is my sanity decreasing fast no imma
die again but I hasn't been saved since
last time because I'm
stupid why why would you do that why
would anybody do that where are you no
no no no I'm by a light I'm by a light
I'm by light oh I forgot using the using
the lighter in the darkness makes you
makes you kind of not happy okay but I'm
fine
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go over here I've got one more lightbulb
I'm gonna replace in here this light is
not broken then why don't it work
okay whatever to store it let's go
upstairs
nope let's store it go upstairs I hate
this oh is that good bad good bad good
bad good bad good bad good bad bad good
good bad bad good good there's lights in
here I'm gonna go in here probably trap
it's a trap but I'm going can i I can't
go in here why can't I go in here oh hi
hi [ __ ] me hi [ __ ] me I [ __ ] me I've
been known to there's been rumors
okay I'm dangerously unsane can let me
go back stand by a candle again I've got
a I got to just put more candles down
I hear the groaning beer it's a good bad
good oh [ __ ] why god damn it
hey listen listen listen I needed those
lungs and you are just being mean you're
being mean
okay so apparently I can't light any
lights anymore so I'm stuck with just
the candles and the camera and the
lighter but if I stand around with the
lighter in the darkness it's just gonna
be bad for me so I got light me up some
candles or else I'm just gonna have the
worst time
Oh my candle I forgot I lit up a candle
over here okay so even though there's a
lot dorkness around I'm gonna be fine
cuz I'm gonna go the other way I'm gonna
go to order way okay even though this
isn't jammed probably yeah it's jammed
what about the other way what about the
other way huh cuz there are two ways in
in here I know this is the fact let me
put a candle right here put that right
there
drop it light it and that's good enough
it'll burn the house down and maybe
that'll be for the best
okay okay hello hello you in here you in
here you in here you in here you're not
in here why well that's a little odd Oh
get out here the power of bear nope
that's a camera
the power oh we're oh it's not work the
power bear the power of Barbara I'm
gonna drop this bear on the other side
hang on let's put this away oh there we
go
okay can I get through how do I get
through can i oh I'm gonna lose my
sanity because I can't get how do I get
through oh there we go I get through I
did it
ah what a lovely place can I have this
please beer beer beer and the birdcage
bear help me beer beer help me beer help
me I'm dangerously low on San bear help
me help me beer help me beer beer help
me please oh I don't like this place
beer help me help me bear bear he'll be
beer okay I've got no nothing I'm gonna
die because I can't bear oh [ __ ] ah beer
help me please
oh you sassy beer mmm beer that's
important looking I'll store that okay
can I get out of that plea I'm about to
die from unsanded of bull reasons can I
get a candle how about a candle look
this one for a candle okay no how about
just for a candle candle no I like this
candle oh I see a candle I don't see
candles I'm candle blind I can't candle
there's no candles there was no candles
no candles no candles there's no candles
there is no candles
Thomas Sam buy this light and assume
that it's gonna help me I'm gonna die
who's there
flash no oh I'm dead I'm a million dead
I'm dead
oh boy I'm dead oh I'm dead okay listen
listen listen ago she ate about this one
nope switch and use okay and then switch
okay then flash okay here we weigh oh
hey whoa hey how you doing
listen listen there's a lamp here just
go for that there see nice so bad so bad
she's afraid of the beer the beer pulled
her into the darkness the power of the
beer is undeniable listen lady I don't
have to use this weapon on you listen I
can be a reasonable guy now that I know
the pun now that I know your one
weakness beer whoa hey whoa I don't have
my beer why I was a fool that's the
light bulb that's up here beer where are
you
bear where are you look up here I got
beer I got there I got beer I got beer
ah that work don't work I don't know
where I'm going
am i doing it where am i okay okay okay
cage room key god is what is this
alright buy me buy me yep doug liman uh
put that be right this is a book open
open open go what is that is it a bird
all good I'm just gonna take a nice sip
of my 32 ounce bottle of beer
well it's jammed oh [ __ ] wait then with
them what do I have to do oh oh that's
Jam - oh no not one of these no no
there's nothing here
oh [ __ ] beer you're my only friend beer
you don't even say craft beer anymore
power is waning beer oh you do is okay
birds oh listen you leave that bird
alone
Thank You Pierre you banish the ghost
once more you're my true friend
Oh
mini mannequin Oh horrible mm uh-huh
uh-huh
pink Oh could this tiny room filled with
tiny boards ah and a tiny or what is
tiny what there's some black goop some
very goopy goopy black goop all right
okay thank you for this enlightening
show this has been special this has been
really truly honestly wonderful thank
you I'm ready to go home now oh that's
not home that is the opposite of home
that's not home all right here we go
it took the beer beer now Oh oh my god
that's the worst thing I've ever seen
holy [ __ ] oh my god oh my god oh hey ha
do I need to run okay oh wow hey at
least I still have my beer hey what is
this this is a mannequin end wait this
is reminiscent of Petey right here
oh [ __ ] it's a mannequin jaw uh-huh okay
all right okay uh I'll put that in my
pocket I I guess okay you Mikey
inventory is really big by the way I
don't know if any of you noticed this
but Mike inventory is rather huge okay
now I know we're last I saw a mannequin
it was downstairs so if I go downstairs
again I'm probably gonna find what I
need right yeah that's right yeah that's
right yeah it seems about right
okay so I'm gonna go downstairs and the
veer off in the direction that I know
there was the mannequin I'm just gonna
gun it and hope for the best that's all
I can do I know I know about the dark
Hey
hi you're here then this mannequin
wasn't here before
I'm aware of that um no how about no oh
how about yes Oh beer yes okay what are
we looking at do I jump in Oh duh duh
Duane and Claire okay Duane and Claire
okay it's Duane and Claire seems to be
non-existent at the moment
okay so what's what was the point of
that I had a candle here by the way can
i light this again thank you okay
what I'll flash your camera at that's
smart you smart you smart you smarty you
big smart
you suck you suck you suck you you suck
you suck oh you suck
oh you suck oh you you suck you should
keep this with you for now okay
well never mind that I guess I'll keep
somehow it won't light up yeah okay
alright okay okay I don't need to
explain and/or justify my actions see I
just did that because I felt like okay
so why it's locked from the other side
okay so a wicker cabinet that I could
kick through in a heartbeat is locked
from the other side okay yeah that's
believable
oh no is this some kind of repeating
hallway oh it is isn't it okay I'm fine
this is very peaty isn't it hello oh I
see I see
Oh what am I looking at okay yeah okay
okay oh oh god oh oh I hate this I can't
see what's going on hello how are you my
name is markiplier I hate everything
about this Oh God take a day life guys
buying a [ __ ] all right anyway so I'm
back into it
hey listen you you're not you when
you're hungry here you're not you when
you're thirsty have a nice cold day see
refreshing beer cool off a little bit
while you relax take the edge off you
seem a little stressed and I there's no
need for stress I'm calm and collected
calm cool collected everybody's happy
anyway what was they doing
hey hey by sitting here it seems I take
a seat uh-huh
hey by over there peekaboo
is that you
ah whatever your name is oh I know the
sound of you anywhere oh really you want
a beer we didn't want a beer hey listen
listen listen Wes Wes Wes less less less
there was no need for that there was no
need for any of that
that is just regard damn Nicholas and
you need to remember ok let's try this
again this time I'm gonna try to be a
little bit quicker about this
I'm gonna go also go the other way let's
close it down I'll act down sounds good
down is exactly what I wanted the whole
time anyway
so why not go down I ask you can I like
this so I'm out ok I can't I can't light
it ok so it doesn't even matter anyway
so I just got looking here what am I
looking at where am I looking where am I
oh thank you slit up now okay that's
good
are you there again okay all right man
people just need to cool their Jets a
bit anybody in here
oh it's locked okay okay okay okay
who did end again am I gonna die
this is how I die isn't it how I die I'm
gonna die
okay maybe not okay so we did that and
that's nice that's real good okay so I'm
gonna open this up again just because I
can and I don't know what else to do
with my life just cuz I want to see I'm
gonna go this way
and hopefully not die and then maybe oh
I knew that was gonna happen then maybe
maybe I won't let the Beast out of the
closet which i think is what I did last
time and that was dumb of me very dumb
instead oh don't give me a hug
okay oh very nice oh no no no no no no
I'm a big nope on that one just kind of
a whole lot of nope just gonna super
know just like a huge
oh I don't think so
don't think so listen listen just gonna
go in here I'm gonna shut the door
everything's good
I'm safe I know I'm safe I know I'm safe
I'm safe I am safe all right let's go
back out now that I'm safe because I am
gonna do it again
safe safe it's gonna be safer than safe
safe
okay oh oh no that's I thought the
shadows were doing something weird oh hi
hello boobs hi how are you good to see
you anyway carry on okay that's nice
thank you don't like that sound
that's probably why is there a lawnmower
up here where is up here what's here
what's in here nothing I shouldn't stop
I should not stop I think I should not
stop not stopping is definitely
something I want to do oh this is bad
oh this is the worst doll hate this oh I
hate this
Oh eenie meenie miney moe catch a demon
by the toe hello oh [ __ ] okay
I hear somebody in here Babu who's here
Babu ski okay
alright then hello who's a big boy who's
a big boy huh
Oh who's a big boy Oh who's a big boy no
okay
big boy in here anybody a big boy here
big boy okay who's your big boy who's
your big boy
we get big boy who's your big boy huh
boo okay all right are you a big boy
whose birthday is it
Oh boom okay all right big boy who's
your big boy
who's your big boy okay who's your big
boy Luigi Luigi
would you big boy where's the big boy
okay
did you is it true I use the biggest boy
okay wait what okay ask me
would you be okay okay oh oh okay I'm
falling who's a big boy
oh here use tidal wave oh God
beer you splash bear beer you're a
genius
beer beer you're so smart beer you're a
thank you beer oh god why is there still
a shadow there okay beer you're so smart
okay beer how are you doing a good job
beer man you have been my invaluable
Ally cuz that would have taken me way
too long to figure out on my own beer
thank you no no no you go back I need to
I drop my camera
no I did not I did not okay here we go
I don't know where we're going but here
we go okay
beer is so smart beer so big smarty beer
biggest smartest big smarty ok happy
oh wait wait this no should I stick my
arm in there I wonder if I should stick
my arm in there I'm gonna stick my arm
in there yeah let's stick on glass right
aha yeah oh okay
why did I do that
someone in there oh you see okay I did
that for a reason I don't know what the
reason was but I did it oh I couldn't
even pick it up afterwards so I'm not
100% sure why but okay
you're always fine guess I'll buy what
I've put my head in there Oh
[Music]
shadows gone I don't know if that's good
or bad
hmm love what you've done with the place
this pop squad
I don't like the way you're looking at
me maybe crack open a cold brewski enjoy
my time in the swamp that's here for
some reason okay and get up now I guess
okay thank you for your hospitality
thank you thank you I guess I don't know
what I don't get it I don't get it I
don't know it hello who's a big boy
who's a big boy who's a big boy is there
anything in there no just a weird closet
okay all right gotcha understood
read you loud and clear big papa okay
don't seem to be anything there was that
yeah no nothing
okay all right okay move this oh wait
this is do I know what this is oh this
is the other way oh cool well at least I
got a chair now their loss
oh yeah chair they ain't gonna stand I
can't get this chair through there we go
I knew I could fit it alright well um
okay now I can pop a squat drink cold
brewski wherever I want
those chair down this stairs here I
don't know why I'm here and I don't know
what I'm going for
oh that that's what that oh wow I get it
okay that make a sense that make a sense
okay now we're getting somewhere now
we're really getting somewhere
oh yeah oh we're getting somewhere okay
where are we getting where's this go
another chair that I can pop a squat
upon okay no need the rusty key good how
many keys do I need and what is it with
like this game what I don't get about it
is and not not not criticized not
christenings all what I don't get about
is like what could possibly be in the
doors that are locked behind early
access it seems like this is the full
game like what else do you need where am
I going I'm going and it's cool I'm not
criticizing it at all no criticizing
here because this is just cool stuff got
the rusty key well fan that that was
easy enough okay so should I go right
back to it then oh oh no I thought that
was a teddy bear looking at me okay well
fine then I guess I'm good I guess I'm
good to go
but what was in here then
what isn't here whoo up no big no big
big bouncing no on that one just a big
giant no I just
nope yeah no big no on that big big no
just the biggest no ok the power of oh I
can't go this way oh good you know what
good good that's good that's for the
best
that's for the best that's for the best
I thought I was gonna have to do
something about that that is for the
best
thank you ok quick drink
let's keep going shall we oh good a dead
end
oh wait bards can I board up the way is
that what I can do
oh alright okay I'll do this I this
seems fine all right here we go
plop run plop her down plop easy-peasy
hey that'll protect me
easy bazoo Zee I couldn't jump that that
would have been impossible that would
have been it unpossible yeah I don't
know what those are maybe the bodies of
the people I shot at the beginning of
the game if that even was me that shot
them no I don't want any of that I don't
want any of that I don't want any of
that I don't want any of that I don't
hold God hi how's it going
oh the dark door that way you say that
way what even is that what am I looking
at I don't want to know but what about
up here and up there what about these
directions this is good oh this don't
look good
this is fine fine that's fine
yup all right some progress ooh
hey friend how you doing okay good to
see you oh boy
why is there a station wagon here why I
have no idea but you know at this point
I guess I don't know why that jumps out
at me is being irrational when
everything else in this game has been
kind of topsy-turvy but you know I'm a
stickler I don't know what I'm a
stickler for but I'm a stickler okay I
don't know where I'm going or why I'm
going up here but here I go I guess man
we got to clean this out this spring
we're gonna clean nothing we can do to
stop it okay wait there's I'm very close
can I can I can I jump up a little just
a little farther just so there we go
okay where am I and what was that wait
what why no am i back am i back am i
back but I didn't go in the shadow door
but but I didn't go in the shadow door
but I didn't go in the shadow door can I
use this no I can't but I didn't go in
the shadow door but but I didn't go in
the shadow door but I didn't go with the
shadow door but I didn't go in the
shadow door I'm following these claws
but the claws go claws stopped I don't
like it I don't like it
Oh
okay it's fine it's jammed why is that
jammed no no no no no no no no no no
uh-uh-uh you can't make me you can't
make me you can't make me you can't make
me you you can't make me
you can you can't make me you can't make
me you Kim that's not right
come in 2+2 it is not this you can't
make me
no no no I see you hi hi hi hello no no
hello I see you you see me I see you no
no no that's water ah [ __ ] - [ __ ] okay
hang on let me just like this up it's
fine how are you
it's fine
that's fine that's definitely fine it's
fine just come sit around
do nothing
is that fill-in is that actually villain
do I have to wait for this to fill up
before something happens before you I
who I see and I see you oh I see you
[Music]
okay I guess this is the game we have to
play we have to do this
peekaboo a good ol game of peekaboo I
don't have pills I don't have pills
there's no pills
there's no pills they took away the
pills I don't have two pills there's no
bells as doll pills and also from the
very beginning of this whole stream
Thank You Logan right for that super
chat you're awesome and everybody at
Logan right cuz there you go
do I have no pills okay
oh are you still there I don't see you
anymore
now he's still jammed
put the hair dryer in there that doesn't
seem like the best idea but I don't know
any better to prove you wrong so well
it's not what do I do
well now I'm just confused hmm oh wait
what whoa wait what wait what since when
did we have lights again since when your
lighter is nearly empty that's fine okay
are we done in here did I do it what I'm
so confused
I'm so confused I can't put it I can't
cuz I can't I can't store it yeah let me
let me layer is empty there's no need to
keep it wait which lighter is empty this
one this one no not that one okay so let
me hang on I'm gonna put this away and
grab this I can't I can't it doesn't
work oh I press the use button on that
oh here I go in the darkness just taking
a nice night bath this is not a logical
thing to do why would I be doing this
why am i doing it no don't
my clothes have I been walking around
this house naked this whole time
Oh either I'm stupid and I dunked my
clothes in or I've been naked this whole
time
oh hi how are you and down I go I guess
is this a contest of who can hold their
breath the longest cuz I'm gonna win
oh no oh okay all right
okey-dokey then okie dokie artichokie
hey yeah don't sit so close to the TV
you're gonna you're you're gonna
no still my beer
I can't hear them they're so quiet but
they took my beer beers gone beers gone
I know all that but who the hell
prescribed syringes for child
clearly doesn't know anything about
parenting I can barely hear them
yeah I'm I turn on subtitles subtitles
I'm gonna sir I'm a slurp on subtitles
I'm gonna blurp on some blonde idols I'm
gonna I'm gonna blurple up some glove
needles I'm gonna I'm gonna Snapple up
some flubbed idols and then you guys are
gonna be able to hear just as goodly and
I'm gonna turn your volume up just your
hair just a little bit so you view a
little more skill wood from the doyen
news mmm okay we got here hello hi
it's just sorry the animations are a
little funny very serious a level of
acting there too also very felt that
passionate but I'm still distraught over
the loss of my beer huh I want to hop
right hit what is it with this what is
it with Duane and baths
Duane just sees a bathtub he was like oh
bathtime lets me shed my clothes and my
pantaloons and hop right in doesn't
matter this filled with blood let go for
a dime come on Oh always time to get
clean cleanliness is next to godliness
as we all know as dream is it the battle
Tao yeah yeah get it in between the toes
that's a good squish yeah just go chest
deep first thing moaning oh no boy okay
great I'm gonna throw up
Oh Stan there I go see I told you I was
gonna win that hold your breath contest
told you zi1
oh hey
[Music]
Oh No whoa Oh
ten beers out of ten
goddamn masterpiece my mama I questioned
some of the decisions that the main
character made but goddamn amazing that
was good I still don't know what the
hell would come out of the early access
stuff or what more there could be but I
would love to see it this game really
truly honestly nailed and I mean nailed
that miss fear the game it nailed it you
had all the tension all of the build-up
and I didn't see what was in the shadow
door what was in the shadow door oh man
and I know there was probably some stuff
that I missed and that was this is a
part of the game because there was even
oh wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute everybody
hold on to your dicks hold on tight beer
ain't done oh you found the safe key
it's very ugly is uh anybody gonna eat
that then may I
ah you found a progress item for now on
then what then what was with that ending
screen is that that's not it that's not
it at all that's not it at all no
everybody buckle it apparently is more
yeah
anyone know what I'm referencing here
are you going to eat that no no I am NOT
then may I sure
okay anyway let's let that go all right
so end of Lucy's chapter a gruesome end
ah I see now what they mean by early
access so that was just a chapter of it
I see I see and I've still got my bear
here all right so what was in the safe
key then or what's in the safe
oh well that one's dead okay drop that
oh never mind
we crashed what you sack of [ __ ] you
sack of [ __ ] at least you waited until
the end of the game to crash on me I'm
going back in we're not done we're not
done we're not done we're not done
everybody hold on hold on to your tits
hold on your dicks hold on to your nips
hold on to your butt cheeks all three of
them and buckle up cuz it's about to get
real it's about to get real
any minute now it's about to get real
for some reason the game is updating now
I don't know why but it ought to be real
there's gonna be real and I'm gonna get
it
hang on everybody hold on to your mmm
navel or by hold on to your necks
everybody hold on to your grundles
everybody hold on to all 13 if your toes
or by hold on to your your your left
right middle and upper ears and get
ready cuz it's about to go down it's
about to go down everybody hold on to
your abdominals only five out of six is
necessary to hold on to get ready cuz
it's about to go down hold on to your
beers most importantly of all yes hold
on to your beers because it's about to
go down all right now we're gonna crash
right away again is that what we're
gonna do are you gonna let me open this
safe
just let me open the safe why don't you
okay there we go okay now what is in the
safe I can't see hold on dear hold on to
your nose hold on to your emotions
barium deep hold them on hold them down
shove them down into the deepest corners
of your self hold them tight and your
bowels hold on to them
cuz it's about to go down Oh
oh dear your knee hold on ear needles
and it's about to go down hold on to the
inside of your rectum hold on to your
your - what's it called the the the the
the anal cavity reflex whatever the the
thing inside your butthole that lets you
tell whether it's a fart or poop hold on
to that hold on to that you out hold on
to that if anything you hold on to okay
we got it we're in it we're in it we're
in it to win it
what is this I can't see I hang on
scooching it around there we go room 302
hold on hold on
because it has already will already is
currently going down and we are going
down with it because we're going down to
the basement to try to find the shadow
door okay all right here we are here we
go it's going down and I'm going down
with it and also thank you everybody so
much for sticking with me through this I
know it's been a fun ride and I don't
know if there's actually any other
content to see here but just thank
everybody that gave super chance through
this livestream thank you everybody the
became a member if I don't see oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh-oh-oh
[Laughter]
I told you guys what did I tell you I
told you it was about to code and did I
lie did I lie did I lead you astray I
told you it was about to go down crack
open your beers it went down and it's
done I'm pretty sure that's probably the
end of it if anything signifies to me
that the developers are like there's
nothing else wait until there's more
[ __ ] that comes out that was really cool
so thank you everybody so much for
watching like I said thank you to all
the people that became a member of the
channel if you did and if you see anyone
does remember to thank them for me if I
don't see it I really do appreciate it
I've got more cool stuff on the way now
that I'm back from Korea and just thank
you in general so much for being here
with me and enjoying this while I'm here
so take care of yourselves check out
other cool scary games that I've played
in the past is that a person staying or
knots it's fine and just in general
thank you so much for being here look
forward to more this as soon as it comes
out and I will play the crap out of it
because it is super super fun so thank
you everybody so much and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
bye here comes a long arduous goodbye
process but good bye good bye good bye